there is so much to be learned from
poker and games in general
so i've tried to transmute poker into my
mission of understanding the games that
we're naturally participating in and i
think that game theory and the systems
thinking that's so necessary to success
has so many wider applications you think
about decision making you think about
human performance being the person who
can show up and perform every day
thinking about understanding yourself
understanding your own psychology i
realized through working with other high
performers in business and investing
that so many of the things that i had to
develop in myself instrumentally to
become one of the best poker players
translated to a number of fields as well
so i think of poker as almost my sandbox
or my lens for understanding how can we
achieve the ambitious things we set out
to achieve how can we
you know find a life of freedom and
purpose it's always been my
avenue of understanding
hey friends and welcome back to deep
dive the weekly podcast where every week
i have the immense privilege to sit down
with authors entrepreneurs creators and
other inspiring people and we find out
how they got to where they are and the
strategies and tools that we can learn
from them to apply to our own lives now
this week it's very exciting because i'm
speaking to a chap called chris sparks
for the first time in real life now
chris is a professional poker player
turned executive coach and he actually
worked with me as my own performance
coach for a period of 90 days during one
of the early lockdowns and so chris
taught me a lot about how to maximize my
performance while it also being
sustainable and working towards the
goals that i personally care about and
how to set those goals that i care about
in the first place and so it was super
nice meeting him in real life and having
this conversation we talked about a lot
of stuff we talked a lot about what it's
like being a professional poker player
and crucially what we can learn from the
world of a professional poker player
around decision making and decision
making under uncertainty and how to deal
with that kind of stuff we also talked a
lot about the frameworks that chris uses
with his clients which are generally
tend to be high-flying executives and
investors and stuff
and me
about like how to actually make sure
you're working on the things that you
want to work on how to set goals
intentionally and how to be more
productive in working towards them so i
hope you enjoy this conversation with
chris box as much as i did if someone's
listening to this and let's say they're
in their 20s and they don't really like
their job and they're thinking oh
playing playing professional poker
sounds like it could be a fun way of
making a living
what does that look like like if i
wanted to start playing professional
poker like what would be the steps i
would have to go through to
become sufficiently pro to get good at
poker and what's the whole deal with is
it like a game of chance versus luck
versus skill like what yeah i'm just
gonna
throw that open to you
ali it's an honor to be here uh giving
uh credence to the title deep dive we
are diving in deep right away i love
that
so yeah what makes a professional poker
player is you have just decided to make
this your main thing right so there are
lots of professionals in things who
aren't necessarily making a living from
it and people who are doing very well
who wouldn't consider themselves
professionals
and i was once a slightly younger than
21 i started when i play started playing
when i was 16 so going at it almost two
decades slightly younger than 21 year
old thinking hey is this something that
i should do
for a living
and what really pushed me over
was i had a moment i wanted to make
television commercials for a living i
was going to be working for ford motor
company i had
done all the internships in school all
the student organizations moved up to
detroit all the networking and what do
you know the economy falls out so this
uh thing that i've been doing instead of
sleep instead of occasionally going to
class
what if i did this as a full-time gig
and what if i really
dedicated myself to it so i think that's
a starting point when you want it you
want to ask yourself hey is this
something that i want to do is are you
willing to dedicate yourself to it there
was a point in time where all my friends
were poker friends all my dreams were
poker dreams it's definitely not
something that you can
just
half-ass it so to say so i couldn't just
do it as a side hustle while working
full-time as a marketing exec or
something like that
no i i think that
things are very competitive these days
and poker is no exception i mean there
are literally millions of people who've
said hey maybe i'll have a go with this
poker and i would say there's probably
less than a thousand who've really
really made it the odds are very much
against because you'd be playing at a
certain level in order to make a living
and with the amount of money that's at
stake people are incentivized to work
very hard and like many things
technology has really evolved the game
whereas when i started eons go it was
pretty much a trial and error to get
better you played a lot of hands if you
won the hand you did a little bit more
of that if you lost the hand you say
okay maybe i'm gonna do that a little
bit less
as the game has evolved it's much more
about
modeling and running simulations so you
see the top players spending on average
about eight hours a day running
simulations of different hands even
before they sit down to play the idea
that the computer as an aide to
determine what is the we call the game
theory optimal approach of playing and
the challenge that anyone has coming
into it fresh is that the people you
will be competing against probably have
thousands of hours on you perhaps tens
of thousands of hours of study on you so
not only do you need to catch up but you
need to be working harder in order to
try to pass them up because they are
going to continue to grow and to improve
a good rule of thumb
is that the average player is about
twice as good on an annual basis so you
can see there's a sense of this red
queen effect you have to be moving very
quickly to stay at the top
um and just like what's the red queen
effect sure so this comes from the
writer lewis carroll so you know alice
in wonderland the idea is like
your things are moving so quickly
that you have to run really quickly just
to maintain your place yep okay all
right so this is like when competitive
and everyone's getting better you have
to be improving just to not fall behind
okay that's poker is a very much a red
queen pursuing that way so you can see
i'm sort of cautioning the 21 year old
know what you're in for and you hear
this narrative a lot with startup
founders or someone who goes out there
and raises an investment fund is if i
knew how hard it was going to be i might
not have ever done it i wonder if you
feel the same way about youtubing
knowing how much work goes into reaching
the top perhaps you wouldn't have
started so there's certainly a level of
naivete that's necessary to get going
but i always ask like are you willing to
put in the work necessary to see if you
have what it takes with something like
poker i would want to
commit to
six months to a year before you're going
to see
even like a semblance of a profit like
there's this sense of you're paying
tuition not in a traditional education
sense but by losing money you will be
losing money at first and it's
impossible to play without having real
money at stake
all of our decision making changes when
there's something at stake imagine that
we were just playing for i don't know
i'm dana miss i feel like pogs or like
pokemon cards something like that that
we don't place all that much value for
we would just be going all in all the
time there's not really all that
incentive to how much incentive to play
smartly to make good decisions well all
of a sudden you're putting the
equivalent of a car in the middle or
let's say even just a very nice bicycle
all of a sudden people's decision-making
processes start to change that's the
thing is like poker is a game played
with cards but it's played in the mind
right it's played with people and how
decision making starts to warp once
there are real stakes at play
so you don't really know how you were
going to perform until you're under that
type of pressure of having some real
stakes yeah
okay
so six or 12 months of study um my
understanding based on like watching
films like 21 and stuff is that
uh and and watching the trailer for
daniel something's master class in
pokemon ground here yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's the one of like oh
crap like you have to be able to do a
lot of calculations in your head and run
probabilities
but i guess that gives you the kind of
optimal game theory
response to a given situation presumably
it's not that hard to learn right
because there's only a finite number of
possibilities or have i just got that
completely wrong like where what's the
skill like where where does the skill
come in beyond learning the basic
probabilities of a four of a kind versus
a full house etc so great question i
think of the math side as table stakes
as you need to at least be able to
estimate the odds in order to have a
chance but there's no advantage there i
think the advantage is all psychological
so understanding other players and most
importantly understanding yourself
there's a real aspect of decision making
under pressure here and it's very hard
to
talk about at an abstract level if you
haven't experienced it personally
and why the game is so interesting is
because people are a black box poker is
a game of imperfect information right
this isn't chess where you can just have
the perfect move you can just plug it
into your computer and it'll tell you
what to do when you memorize it you're
trying to predict what other people have
based off of their behavior so there's
an element of deception and certainly an
element of self-deception that's
occurring so a lot of the mastery
self-deception why self-deception in
both hey i am
telling a story with the actions that
i'm taking my my betting patterns that i
have this type of hand
but really i'm playing my hand
not as that my hand actually is but as
all the hands that i could have as a set
of possibilities or as a set of hands
that i want you to think i have that's
why i say the game is played in your
minds is that like the cards are really
only an interface for what's going on so
it's kind of like those lying games
where
if you if you know you're the mafia uh
but you're acting as if you really you
really want to believe that you're not
because then you will act as if you're a
good guy rather than a bad guy and
you're kind of convincing people to
think that you're a good guy even though
you actually know you have a bad guy
card yeah i don't think that people are
very good actors instead of trying to
pretend hey i have a really big hand you
guys should fold i think it's easier to
fool yourself into i have a good hand so
i'm just going to act as if i have a
good hand right i'm not acting i'm just
doing what i would normally do but i've
sort of over wrote that part of my brain
and says i have this hand or that hand
sorry i interrupted you when i was when
you were saying the mastery of
yeah
there is there is a sense of
no situation repeats like you can have
you have limited combinations of cards
but because all the variables change all
the time you're continually adapting to
changing situations and that's why
experience is so valuable because you
start to be able to identify the
patterns within the noise and see the
situation where a lot of beginning
players struggle
is that they don't understand the
absolute strength of the hand versus the
relative strength of the hand without
getting too technical sometimes a good
hand isn't all that good and sometimes a
good hand is amazing and a lot of that
just comes down to experience and
repetition and iteration of
understanding the situation that's
occurring and it's something that you
can't really read in a book you have to
start to
calibrate your intuition in this way and
so just the maths is like
everyone knows the math that's not the
hard part the hard part is actually
being able to play the mind game to
deceive yourself and then also also to
deceive other people and the people that
are good at this are have had 20 000
hours more preparation on this than i
have and therefore if i try to play
poker with them with my even with the
basic knowledge of the maths there's
almost no way i'd be able to actually
beat them consistently over the long
term the challenge is that people are
constantly adapting right system strings
would say the poker is a complex
adaptive system that as soon as you
figure someone out they change right
it's just that they're people aren't
static so that's where you see
expert players or they're able to adapt
faster
they're sort of setting a trap you think
they're playing in a certain way but
they've already preset a counter to that
and that and that's why i say like the
game is continually evolving is in order
to sustain your place at the top you
need to not only be evolving on a
session level on a game level but as a
player so that people can't get a real
sense for what your tendencies are
because you have no tendencies
nice okay another sort of basic question
what's what's the deal with online poker
versus real life poker these days if i
were thinking of getting into poker can
i just get really good at playing online
poker and make loads of money that way
how does that work
it really depends on skill set i think
that online poker is more statistically
based whereas live poker is much more of
a social game
so everything goes in cycles and we see
cycles that online poker becomes much
more popular 2020 and 2021 online poker
was much more popular for obvious
reasons so everyone kind of gravitated
back towards things you could do inside
on your computer
and i'm primarily known as an online
poker player and a lot of my skill came
from deep statistical analysis of myself
and other players to reveal correct
strategies in a variety of situations
but the primary advantage of playing
online is that you can play multiple
games at a time
so i've played a maximum of 30 games at
a time
my average is around 12. what this means
is that i'm getting a new hand every two
seconds on average so i'm making
decisions every two seconds for hours at
a time and there's this concept that i
like that improvement speed is
proportional to the tightness of your
feedback loops which is a fancy way of
saying that the more decisions that
you're making and the more that you're
iterating on decisions you're making
based off of feedback you get this work
this didn't work the faster you improve
as a player so because i was playing so
many games and being very systematic
about the way that i improved i improved
very very quickly
and think about it just in pure math
terms if i'm playing 12 games i'm
getting about 600 hands per hour at a
typical live game at a home or a casino
you're getting about 20 to 25 hands per
hour so this means that playing online
i'm seeing 25 to 30 times as many hands
so that means i can win 25 to 30 times
as much playing the same sticks or i can
play smaller stakes and have lower
variance those are these are different
factors at play
but
online over time because of these tools
available that i shared before has
gotten increasingly competitive over
time and because it's a global player
pool you're competing against the best
players in the world so
and my view on average online has gotten
much much more difficult over over time
now what we've seen host pandemic
everyone going outside and going out is
that live poker in person is having
another another renaissance particularly
term and poker my specialty is cash game
poker you know tournament poker you have
one buy-in you're trying to compete over
a prize pool which is very top-heavy
jewelry the price will go to the top few
finishers in a cash game you're putting
you know actual chips or bricks cash in
the middle so you're betting what you
actually have in front which i imagine
changes the psychology of how people
take risks and stuff absolutely and
because
termite poker excited is a power law
distribution so it's very top-heavy it
really rewards risk-taking whereas cash
game poker is more of a i think it's
like a cash flow of business it's a
little bit more consistent you're trying
to you know maintain discipline not get
too out of line that sort of thing and
it's it's more you're i play with the
same 50 players every day so it's much
more of a long term
you know it's an iterated game in game
theory terms so i'm not only thinking
about what's the right move to do now
but how does this move set up my
opponents you know weeks from now
because because i'm playing with them
every day i have many many opportunities
to capitalize on something that i've set
them up on it's a very different
approach so it's more like hey if i
fold right now then they'll think that
i'm the sort of person who folds under
these conditions which means four weeks
from now they'll use that data point to
make a decision which is actually going
to be bad for them
exactly
and this is you know one of the other
many definitions of a professional
player is that everything has you know
what we call second order effects so
you're already thinking about what
of these options that i have now what's
the next layer on the game tree what is
going to be my opponent's reaction when
i show this hand what action do i want
to take that sets them up for what i
want to do later if you find your
opponent has a weakness say they play a
particular particular type of hand
really poorly you want to make that
situation happen as much as often so you
can take maximum advantage of them that
type of thing there's there's all these
really interesting layers just to close
out this thought on live poker which
just has research as everyone's playing
in person again there's been this really
big boom of stream games so kind of a
hybrid of online and live where you play
poker in person in a studio setting and
people tune in and watch on youtube as
some people watching might be familiar
with this that you know gaming on stream
has become really big and we have this
resurgence of poker celebrities people
who have a character they play someone
on the stream and people tune in to see
what this person is going to do next
while they play poker so live poker is
much much more about social dynamics
being someone who understands the room
who understands what people are doing
energetically knows how to pick up when
someone's mood has shifted or knows hey
this person just got an argument with
their significant other or they look
under-slept or maybe they're not quite
as focused today there's because like
for example one of these stream games
you're playing five hours so you have a
hundred hands and that very very small
sample size so they make most of it you
have to you have to be much much more
attuned to each individual hand and
trying to extract down maximum value
that's the main difference between live
and online is online i can just play my
strategy i'm seeing seen two million
hands in my lifetime i'm playing for the
very long term and live poker like every
hand really matters because you don't
get many more of them so there's a lot
more signal to drag to draw from nice so
i go so many layers deep as many as you
want we are interrupting this episode to
bring you the good news from our sponsor
which is short form short form is the
world's best service that summarizes
books but it's way more than just book
summaries they have book summaries yes
and they are by far the best service
i've ever used for book summaries and
i've used all of them basically they've
got book summaries but they also have
these interactive exercises in between
chapter summaries which are really
helpful for engaging more with the ideas
in the book and they also have these
little short form note segments where if
the author for example vicky robbins of
your money or your life if she says
something that's particularly
controversial or that another author or
source disagrees with short form will
usually find that out and will say hey
by the way this thing that she says
about the idea of money has been
disagreed with by morgan hessel's book
the psychology of money and they'll link
to the book and they'll say here is here
are the three reasons why morgan housel
disagrees with vicky robbins and it's
just interesting it's great because it
gives you a level of critical insight
into books that me for me personally i
don't really get otherwise for me the
two main ways i use short form is
firstly uh if i'm thinking about reading
a book if someone has recommended a book
to me and it happens to be on short form
which it usually is then i'll often read
the summary first and if i like the
summary and i think oh this would be an
interesting book to read then i'll
actually read the book or alternatively
if i've read the book sometime in the
past and i want to revisit the lessons
from it then i'll often look up the
summary on short form and go through my
kindle highlights if it's a thing i
highlighted on kindle and it's just a
great way for me to revisit the ideas in
the book if any of that sounds up your
street then head over to short form dot
com forward slash deep dive and that
link also in the video description and
the show notes is gonna give you 20 off
the annual premium subscription so thank
you so much short form for sponsoring
this episode one of the things i like to
think about when someone has an
interesting career or side hustle or
something is to ask for a complete
beginner how hard would it be to
make a couple hundred dollars a month
versus a couple thousand dollars a month
versus a couple of tens of thousands
tens of thousands of dollars a month and
i can i can i can i can kind of think of
what that looks like from a youtube
channel perspective okay cool let's say
take average cpms and rpms let's reverse
engineer this actually as a youtuber if
you're consistent and post two videos a
week for two years chances are and you
find the right niche probably make at
least a few hundred dollars a month
maybe even a few thousand and then if
you really make it big then you're
getting in the tens and hundreds of
thousands which is fairly small numbers
but a lot of people
might be like hey if i could do two
videos a week and make an extra few
hundred dollars a month that would be
great like that's an extra five shift
shifts as working working as a doctor
for example in return for making videos
and so the equation
that that that equation in terms of
monetization on youtube means that there
are a lot of people going into it
thinking oh it's a thing i could do as a
side hustle i could be a part-time
youtuber i might as well do this what
does that look like in the world of
poker online poker live but like
if i wanted to make pocket money versus
real money versus life-changing money
i talk about this in a post i did called
play to win i think
the niche argument or the niche framing
is really apt here is if you find a good
game you can make unlimited money right
it's not a fact skill is not the
predominating factor it's choosing the
right place to compete right so for
example if you're making videos
on oh this is just like complete off top
of my head like
polar bears in alaska ah this is
that's a pretty small niche and if you
can find hey this is really valuable to
a small but reliable set of people you
can make a really good living there the
same sort of thing if you are in alaska
and you stumble upon you know a small
town but it happens to be a few people
who've done very well in the polar bear
trade and like to play poker you don't
have to be very good if you're better
than these players right and so that's
the real difference about poker is that
it's relativistic skill
and i think a lot of success
in life comes down to playing in the
right game playing in the place that
you have
some sort of advantage
and even if that advantage is you just
enjoy doing this more you have more fun
at it thus your your
have an easier time dedicating yourself
to it putting yourself into it and
that's the thing about poker is the the
earnings are pretty unlimited if you can
find a good game
so that that's really the critical skill
is like finding this this like product
market fit so if you want to earn a
little bit you're probably playing lower
stakes if you want to if you want to
earn a lot you're playing high stakes
and obviously the higher that you go
generally the player gets better right
the larger incentive you have to get
good the more competitive it is it tends
to look like a pyramid is that there's
very very few people at the top
but poker is weird because you also have
people who love to play poker who are
extremely successful in other areas of
their lives right maybe they sold their
company maybe they have you know
millions of followers on youtube maybe
they haven't maybe their big hedge fund
guy and they love competing against the
best they really love that sense of like
i'm learning the most i'm having the
most fun and so these guys love to play
for big stakes sometimes uncomfortably
big stakes but they're not very good
yeah so there's this conception that
the higher you go the harder that it is
to play and that's not always true some
of the other players might be
exceptionally good there's gonna be
other players who are not as good but
the higher the up that you get
the key thing is like can you get into
the game it's like what do you bring to
the table like at the lower stakes you
can always find a game but beyond a
certain point it's very difficult to get
in because it's like musical chairs
right there's not enough chairs for
everyone yeah
so
okay so so it sounds like
if for example i am a
uh i'm let's say a consultant surgeon at
my local hospital and i know that there
is a group of surgeons who likes to get
together and play poker and they all
have private practices and they will
make several several hundred thousand
pounds a year and i know that they just
throw a few thousand pounds into this
sort of poker game which is pretty high
stakes as far as things are concerned
for me i might be thinking hang on if i
can get into those games if i can like
be likeable enough and oh talk to this
person in the break room in in the
operating theater and be like oh you
play poker i play poker too
i just have to be a little bit better
than them and if they're you know
consultant surgeons with private
practices and full-time jobs and
families and i'm not i can put in just
way more time and effort to get better
than them but because i have access to
that game i can now potentially even
make a decent chunk of money
whereas someone with the same skill
trying to play online will just get
completely demolished is that fair to
say that's exactly right people have
gone into med school for less
uh what does it take to get invited to
these big big games i think it's just
like getting invited to any party or
having a good friend circle being
someone who's likable and adds value
so all i can control is you know the
presence that i bring so trying to be
someone who's positive energy
who you know tells good stories laughs
at the right jokes you know shows up on
time pays out when i lose it's just
someone who like is adding to the
atmosphere right the same thing is like
oh how do i get invited to more parties
well be someone that people want at your
parties how do i find the love of my
life be the type of person that the love
of your life is attracted to the same
sort of thing so rather than thinking
like oh how can i find my way in again
this is this is personal it's like oh
how do i befriend these people it's more
like hey just just be someone who's cool
and you'll find a way yeah i guess it's
like that thing of it's a lot easier to
i just
when you have a hand to act as if you
have the right hand rather than to try
and finesse your way using specific
strategies to
act as if you have that right hand i.e
just become the sort of person that gets
invited to these sorts of things and if
you have a bit of an alpha in terms of
being better than poker better at poker
than the average person there chances
are you'll make some money
yeah it seems to be this unfortunate
fact of life and that the people with
the most opportunities are the people
who get the most opportunities that a
sense of just
not needing it means that people throw
it at you
so i'm always trying to operate from
this place of abundance and that i don't
need anyone anything from anyone and
that certainly seems to be a way to
attract more abundance into my life
nice okay so
it sounds like poker is a lot harder
than initially than like uh these online
course videos that well that you'll get
on youtube videos be like hey make a
thousand dollars an hour playing poker
online
uh probably a lot harder than those make
it seem yeah yeah not not to get too
meta but if anyone out there
if or any this goes for anything is
trying to make it sound like it's easy
think about like well why is this person
making this course anyways like if it
were that easy why wouldn't they be
doing it themselves instead of making a
course yeah yeah that's really what was
your poker career like you said you kind
of got serious about it at the age of 21
what did that look like when were you
and in your heyday and then why did you
ultimately i guess retire from from the
online stuff
yeah i'll give the super abbreviated
version i was always a gamer growing up
i was uh best in the world a game called
microsoft ants at a very young age i
started playing this game called gin so
it's a two-player form of rummy achieved
a perfect elo rating or at least
equivalent of elo for gin some of my gin
friends online said hey you can play
this other card game for money and
called poker so i was sitting in my you
know my parents living room on our dial
up internet and entering into what
called free roll tournaments this is
when i was 16. hey if you
finished the top 10 in this tournament
out of 10 000 players you win a thousand
bucks which seemed like an infinite
amount of money so many shoes that i
could buy with that thousand dollars i
entered into college this guy named
chris moneymaker had won the world
series of poker so all of a sudden poker
is on tv everywhere and if you're a
collegiate male like this is what you
did for fawn on friday night on saturday
night and many other nights so started
playing some of these dorm games with
friends and they said oh you can
actually play for real money online and
realize hey these guys that i'm playing
with aren't very good and they're making
money i could probably do that too so i
started playing tournaments and then
later cash games during my time in
university at ohio state and got to the
point that i was doing very well i was
you know kind of like middling level
making a nice living had paid off all my
loans that sort of thing i mentioned i
graduated this you know coming up from
uh you know middle class household first
kid in college like oh okay obviously i
get a job and i progress through this
average corporate ladder luckily economy
had other plans and i was forced to like
hey why don't i do an experiment and
treat poker as a full-time thing and see
what happens a couple months later i was
making what my annual salary would have
been every month and said hey maybe i
should do a little bit more of this
poker thing i moved out to los angeles
with some of my closest friends who i'd
only knew online at this point after my
21st birthday and really dedicated
myself to it started teaching a lot of
other poker players created a consulting
practice later an investment firm around
it and you know fast forward 18 months
of going full time i was ranked top 20
in the world i like to say it was like
dion sanders top of my career when we
had as american football reference for
all you guys across the pond we had was
called black friday where online poker
was shut down in the u.s so this is my
my first sort of forced retirement at
23. i decided i wanted to take a break
from poker started traveling backpacking
actually didn't play a single hand of
poker for five years
and there was a another poker boom that
lured me out i heard about things that
were happening in china so these are
games that they were taking place over
apps sort of the equivalent of like a
zynga you're playing with gold coins
those gold coins are representative of
real dollars via intermediary kind of
like essentially
you know gray area type stuff but you
know really good games friends started
learning mandarin so they could get into
these games like people people go
through all levels this got me back into
poker and luckily i stumbled back into a
new renaissance within us online poker
because it'd been shut down a lot of
other the best players had left the us
to keep playing and news sites popped up
and thus i was able to immediately hop
back in after five years not playing
essentially be at the top of my game did
really really well through the pandemic
and then you know the last year or so
i've been really focusing on playing in
person particularly in these stream
games so i've had multiple retirements
you know usually i call more like
sabbaticals i take you know three to six
months off at one point you know took
whole five years off but poker has
always been there as a background i
think of it as my sandbox for
performance to make sure that i'm
walking the walk
hey team hope you're enjoying this
episode uh just giving you a little
message from our sponsor which is
shopify which is incredibly exciting
because we've been using shopify the
platform for over a year now to host our
online store and shopify is just a
incredible super easy to use fantastic
platform for building any kind of online
business you can sell stuff online you
can sell stuff in person you can sell
stuff with almost any payment method in
almost any country it's absolutely sick
and you can get started with shopify
without needing anything like knowing
how to code or knowing how to design
because their pre-existing designs are
absolutely sick and we are now using
shopify for basically hosting all of our
ecommerce stuff including our physical
products the essentially stationary line
which i've designed recently we're using
shopify to host our digital downloads
like notion templates and website themes
and we're also using shopify as the
payment provider for our courses which
then hooks up into our courses platform
so it's just incredible it's got
thousands and thousands of integrations
so you can integrate with almost
anything imaginable i genuinely highly
recommend signing up shopify and at
least checking it out you can head over
to shopify.com forward slash ali abdal
and get a totally free trial to shopify
so you can see whether you like it and
you can kind of build your own store and
you can see what the vibe is it's just
great and thank you so much shopify for
sponsoring this episode why do you
care about poker like
it sounds like your
view it's it's it sounds like
part of it is you have fun doing it
another part of it is you make money
doing it so you're like yeah might as
well um is there is there something
beyond that is there like a wider
mission purpose behind this thing or is
it kind of those two those two factors
yeah i i can only guess in my
motivations right i think we all just
like to tell stories about ourselves
i think that there is so much to be
learned from poker and games in general
so i've tried to transmute poker into my
mission of understanding the games that
we're naturally participating in and i
think that game theory and the systems
thinking that's so necessary to success
has so many wider applications you think
about decision making you think about
human performance you being the person
who can show up and perform every day
thinking about understanding yourself
understanding your own psychology i
realized through working with other high
performers in business and investing
that so many of the things that i had to
develop in myself instrumentally to
become one of the best poker players
translated to a number of fields as well
so i think of poker as almost my sandbox
or my lens for understanding how can we
achieve the ambitious things we set out
to achieve how can we
you know find a life of freedom and
purpose it's always been my
avenue of understanding
what are some of those skills that you
think are sort of cross-applicable from
poker to other areas of life i guess i'm
kind of thinking the ones that someone
watching this or listening to this would
be able to
kind of yeah would be applicable to them
because i imagine knowing how to count
cards is not one of them but i'm sure
there's a whole world of others
sure i'll share one that's probably my
favorite lesson from poker so we have
this concept called expected value and
you know as any gamer knows you start to
abbreviate things in a lot of terms so
we're just always ev it's like plus cv
minus ev so like something has expected
value something doesn't have expected
value so
small bit about math right you don't
need you can't get advantage from the
math but you have to know it expected
value is on average
what is the expected outcome from doing
this it's a way to calculate it is for
each
instance
it's the
how good it is
multiplied by what percentage it is
happening
so you say like flipping a coin right 50
chance i've had certain chance of tails
it evens out but if you say something
more like all right i'm going to
pay you two dollars if it's heads and
you're gonna pay me one dollars if it
tails okay two times fifty cent two
times fifty percent is one
plus one times fifty percent is fifty so
every time we do this i bet a dollar
expect to make a dollar fifty so i'm
making 50 cents every time we do it
right so expand this out every action
that we take has an expected value you
have some form of risk and some form of
reward and so the way that my brain
works through just getting punched in
the face so many times in poker is just
like
is the ru is the risk worth reward or
like all the options available to me
what has the highest expected value and
so that's anything of like okay what
restaurant am i going to go to what am i
going to order at that restaurant who
should i go over and talk to this person
should i reach out to this person that i
want to talk to thinking about okay well
what's the upside of this what what do i
what am i putting at risk what are the
other things that i could be doing
instead the opportunity cost and once
you start to just wear this idea of
expected value like close you realize
that everything is a bet you talk to
people about poker be like oh well i
don't gamble it's like okay well
everything you do is a bet you're every
action that you take you're saying like
this step forward gets me somewhere and
so you're decomposing all your actions
into like is this a good bet
and that's why the way i've sort of seen
my life is just i'm taking all these
tiny
calculated risks that i expect will get
me one step closer to where i want to be
that's great this idea of plus ev i i
guess
another thing from this concept is that
you're not wedded to the outcome of an
individual decision as long as it was
plus cv because like over time like i'm
i'm i'm just kind of thinking yesterday
we had a call with this marketing agency
that's like wants to do some tick tock
stuff for us and i feel like you know
they're charging quite a lot of money
but i in my mind i feel like it's plus
ev i feel like a decision like that is a
distance a decision we should just say
yes to because
fine it costs a certain amount of money
but like we'll it'll probably pay off
and even if it doesn't like
if we had 10 of those other
circumstances it would
like
you know on average the decision would
be a good one to take
and when you said plus savey i was like
ah yes that's what i was trying to get
to and i was trying to explain it to the
team as to why i think this is a good
idea because i think it's very easy for
individual decisions to over index on oh
but what if this doesn't work and then
that makes you quite risk averse because
the whole bias towards avoiding a loss
versus realizing again i i think it's
one step beyond that of course risk
aversion is true and that we tend to
overvalue risk and undervalue gains and
i think generally in life the biggest
risks are the risk not taken because you
forego all learning i think it goes one
step beyond that i think it's moving
beyond thinking in results terms and
more thinking and process orientation
terms
so let's say that you had this call with
the marketing agency and it was a
complete waste of time it'd be easy to
walk away from that and being like okay
i'm never talking to any more marketing
agencies again that was a complete waste
like well did you know that it was going
to be a waste time before you got on
that call maybe you had there was no
sign and it was still a plus ev thing to
do even if it didn't work out because
now you learn okay these are all the
things we definitely don't want an
agency or here are all the reasons why
we definitely want to keep this in-house
that sort of thing
or you could take a step back and say
all right what were those signs that we
could have saw before the call this
could have been a waste of time were
there any things that we missed or
overlooked or overweighted you realize
that in this equation all of these
variables are unknown right life is not
flipping a coin we have to just make
guesses and estimates sorry like i'm
playing poker i don't know the exact
percentages of everything but i'm very
very good at making estimates and
continually calibrating those estimates
over time so think about okay like how
risky is this really everything that we
do every encounter every time we bump up
against reality we learn a little bit
more about what those actual
probabilities risk rewards are and so we
get a better sense of like what risks
are worth it and what rewards are worth
it over time through this feedback that
we're getting
so it's not just oh this worked out this
didn't work out is
how does what happen
how does that tell me about the
assumptions that i came into during this
decision right did i was i literally
would say that going back to this
marketing agency call was i a little bit
too excited about this whole idea of a
marketing agency taking over everything
or was i like a little bit too
underestimate of the cost and whatever i
would have to do involved and you take a
step back and say okay presuming that
this type of situation is going to be
recurring how do we change our approach
slightly so that we make it something
that's a little bit more use of our time
i think this is the critical variable to
solve for in all of our lives is how do
we solve for we call self-organization
that processes automatically improve
over time that every time we do
something it creates a jumping off point
to iterate and improve that process
every time we do it so i think that's
that's the real that's the real learning
is that the expected value it's not just
floating out there in the world we have
real control over these variables yeah
it's like a thing that i've heard tim
ferriss say a few times which is that
like when when he was starting his
podcast as an experiment it was like
how do i skew the circumstances in my
favor such that even if this thing fails
i will still have learnt a lot from it
and it would be have been a worthwhile
thing to do whereas i think yeah that
makes a lot of sense i think like i
haven't used this concept in my youtuber
academy but we're in week four of our
five-week course now and i'm just
thinking actually a lot of this applies
to the whole starting a youtube channel
or not going down this niche versus
versus that niche
where we're operating with imperfect
information and a lot of a lot of the
times a student will ask us hey what do
you think about this niche and it's like
like i honestly i couldn't tell you i
would have to sit down and do a ton of a
ton of research and and even then i
would have very unperfect information
and so i would just have to try and see
what happens
but i think
yeah thinking about it in that like
you know would it for example be plus ev
to at least try and experiment in that
and learn from it and then come back and
regroup
might be an interesting way of
explaining it i think you're already
doing it my understanding of what you
talk about with youtube is that you just
need to make videos that reps are their
own reward that you learn so much about
the experience of like hey people
responded to this people didn't respond
to this that automatically by making
videos those videos improve over time
you can't optimize up front you need
that you need to close that loop of
feedback what do you like talking about
what is your where is your audience
already what are they interested in what
do they respond to what types of videos
seem to get through type response
there's no substitute for putting things
out there so i think it's like a race to
feedback and that's why i say this this
ev you have control over it because
everything that you do you get a little
bit more attuned to what the odds are
and you can make those decisions
a little bit more systematically right
and that's why i said it's like it's
more when i'm when i'm talking about
like okay this is a person i want to
build a relationship with i think i
think this comes down to like mentors
business partners hiring
the thing i like to say is you want to
look at the x not the why is we're not
where is this person currently how
successful are they what have they done
but what is their trajectory so like the
person who's going to go on to do
amazing things has a high trajectory and
that looks like they have a fast
iteration speed they're learning and
even if they're making mistakes they
learn from those mistakes and keep
improving right every video they put out
has another small tweak that's that's
better that's something that i'm always
looking for is like not where this
person is where they project them to be
a few years down the line if they keep
improving because that's the thing it's
a hockey stick the improvement speed
goes exponential
hmm
that was that was one of the biggest
factors we used to hire one of our
interns sam who has a youtube channel
it's not hugh i mean it's a few thousand
subscribers so it's like it's not like
incredibly huge but it's like pretty
reasonable but i think the thing that
was most impressive was the fact he's
got about 60 or 70 videos in the last
year which means he's just making a
video to every week he's like ah damn we
want the sort of person on our team who
is the sort of person that makes a video
every week or two while they're doing
their degree and that is just like a
thing that is actually you know it's
it's it sounds like somewhat right on
the surface but is indicative of a
deeper sort of the the sort of person
that this person is is the sort of
person that moves fast on things and
iterates and puts stuff out there
without being without being 100
sure it's perfect which is the sort of
person we want on our team yeah if you
want to extend this to productivity it's
like the 90 of success is showing up
like almost everything annoyingly so
comes down consistently consistency
showing up putting in the work over and
over and the systematic is like every
time you do something okay what went
well let's do a little more of that well
it didn't go so well okay what are we
going to try differently next time what
are we learning from that and you can
see the people who are consistent day in
and day out start to distance themselves
it's like we always want to approach it
as like all right how do i find this
like perfect process this perfect system
and then like everything is going to be
solved it's like no you still got to
show up and be consistent and that's the
thing that you know doesn't sell at
books of course is like how do you
become the type of person who's showing
up and i think this really comes back to
one just like living life with a sense
of curiosity like hey
i want to know what happens here let's
let's see let's find out let's try it
but also like what is your why what is
your mission what is that thing that's
going to cause you to stay consistent to
stick it out to pull through when you
put something out there and not a single
person views it or you put a post out
there and no response it's all crickets
like what's going to allow you to push
through to get to that point of breaking
through
is the sense of mission the sense of
curiosity of like okay i did an
experiment it didn't work out well what
did i learn from that what am i going to
try differently next time and just keep
putting things out there yeah there's a
lot of things that's like connecting in
my head as you say that one thing that i
i remember a piece of advice i remember
getting when i was in medic in medical
school everyone who's trying to go for
these jobs and stuff is trying to go
after publications because if you get
two publications you get two extra
points on your thing which increases
your chances of being in london because
those two points are two points of alpha
that no one else has because it's quite
hard to get publications and so the next
question is okay how do i get these
publications and a couple of senior
students just said to me look just make
friends with all of the doctors you ever
meet in the hospital it would be nice to
them and then ask them at some point
once you've made friends with them hey
do you have any projects that i can help
you with
and through that i got my two
publication points that was great and
then younger students would ask me how
do i get these publication points i'd be
like honestly just make friends with the
doctors and just ask them do you have
any projects any projects i can help
with
and this connects to something that
happened yesterday so one of our team
members asked was this was in the office
and said hey you know i i want to i'm
involved in this aspect of the business
i want to get involved in more aspects
of the business so like how should i do
that and this i i had like 10 seconds
before i had to go to something else so
i was like honestly just like be in the
office a bit more and
just by virtue of doing that by virtue
of showing up in the room where
conversations are happening where those
conversations are not being barred from
anyone but it just so happens that the
people that show up here in person
more often will
automatically be plugged into more
conversations that are happening than
the people that don't and of course in
an ideal world
hybrid team we'd find a way to make it
accessible for everyone who's not even
here but like in the real world
if a conversation is happening
serendipitously no one's going to hop on
zoom to update the for eight people who
want here but the five people who are
here are now now feel as if they're part
of something this makes me think of my
concept of the most direct path
is when you understand what you're going
to accomplish and what it's necessary to
get there you can identify the most
direct path to get there so in your case
recognizing okay i want to get this
residency and this requires these two
recommendations i'm getting the
terminology wrong but just to generalize
it all right so all the other things i
could be doing matter so much more so
much less than getting the two
recommendations so what is that most
direct path to getting those two
recommendations okay who has the power
to write those why don't i go and talk
to them and there's so many aspects of
this talking to a client the other day
who's like okay i have a really big
product launch coming up and i'm i'm
coordinating across all these channels
and i'm putting out a bunch of posts and
okay let's let's take a step back let's
say the launch was successful what
happened well it's like these five
influencers probably talked about it's
okay well have you reached out to those
influencers like all this other stuff
you're doing is great but if this is the
criteria for success like go directly at
it make sure if these five influencers
are that influential talk to them
directly that gives them something of
value so that you make sure that you
solve for this part of the puzzle and i
think this is really that difference
between productivity and performance
that we love talking about is
productivity there's a lot of things you
can do that'll make you feel good at the
end of the day is like i tried i did all
these things i did my best that sort of
thing when you take a step back and say
all right what does success look like
now doing those things which are likely
to be more ambiguous maybe harder a
little bit more risky but most on that
direct path that's how you start to
maximize your time and your ev
um
yeah
that's great i'm just thinking about
that in terms of yeah just thinking
about my team as well where if someone's
like i want to get more involved with
the business where it's like okay cool
like
i mean just like make something happen
then and the most direct password
getting more involved with the business
is to do a thing that the business needs
outside of your current role and being
like hey i've done this thing and that
would be like oh sick thank you here are
some other things that we can do and
suddenly that person becomes a lot more
valuable and i guess this applies to any
job as well where yes
yeah i think this is a good extension of
this whole understand the game that
you're playing and know where the rules
can be subverted so imagining that
you're applying for the job and everyone
loves to just go in through the front
door and throw the resume on the pile
and said on the interview but like take
a step back and say okay who is this
person hiring what are they looking for
how can i make myself stand out and make
myself the obvious candidate for the
role yeah so instead of answering a
bunch of questions they say okay under
show you understand their business or
you understand their problem really
intimately and make some sort of
proposal that hey this is how i would
solve it and make sure that those are
things that you can do and say hey like
if you pick me
i will solve this problem for you yeah
that's a lot different than like oh i'm
going to hire this person to do these
things i'm going to have this person
solve this problem for me
but that really that comes back to again
is empathy and thinking about all right
here's the way that all the other people
are playing the game and that's great
but it feels really competitive over
here what's the back door that i can get
in that no one's thinking about because
the rules are are made up right somewhat
you don't need to necessarily follow
okay you go to interview like most jobs
are filled
off yeah offline
so it's like all right how can i go to
that person directly and make myself
indispensable and you realize that like
life is just full of these false velvet
ropes that are really just there to keep
out the people who want to stay within
the rules now i'm not saying just like
call her all over and make it all up but
like there's a lot of room to take a
step back and be creative and think
about what do i bring to it
yeah
and i i think i think on the yeah just
on this job application topic there is
there seems to be a lot of from what
i've i've heard almost
a combination of moralizing and
expectancy or like i applied for this
job properly that was there that was
therefore the right thing to do and oh
my god this company didn't get back to
me wow what a mean company i would not
want to work for them anyway because
they clearly don't value their
candidates because they didn't reply to
my thingies
and it's like now having been on the
other side of it and being like we've
got like freaking 5 000 applicants and
the guy who who got hired was the only
guy who made a video knowing that we are
a freaking video making business like
i'm not even going to read the other
1000 because like i haven't got time for
that and it's like i
now being an employer i'm like bloody
hell like
i wish i could
every single person i know who's
applying for jobs i could just be like
hey just act genuinely try and have
empathy for the employer like get into
their heads don't think of employers a
dirty capitalist who's just like
profiting off the sweat off your back
and like exploiting you et cetera et
cetera i just like genuinely think if i
were running a business and i had a
zillion things to do
how would i make it easy for myself to
get hired in this situation
i mean you're asking about poker lessons
it's understanding the other person
better than they understand themselves
better than understanding their problem
better than they can define it finding
this back door this uh this reminds me
of like if i could just play armchair
psychologists a bit i think the
challenge that we have in productivity
in finding happiness and fulfillment is
that so much of our cognitive
infrastructure is there to just be able
to pat ourselves on the back like good
job you tried you know you applied to 10
jobs hey you didn't hear back but like
they're lost they don't see you and
thinking about well all right perhaps
the way that i'm doing things isn't
working it doesn't mean that i'm bad it
means that i'm not playing the game well
so how can i play this game
better i think about like playing one of
these like like a street fighter mortal
kombat back in the day right so they're
always like projectile and so you'd have
like this annoying kid you're playing
it's just like projectile projectile
projector projectile and the response is
always like oh that's cheap you gotta
you gotta punch and kick that's not the
right way it wins what well is it within
the rules of the game
yes okay then it's not cheap but we go
through life like this is like oh
there's a right way to play and it's
like i have to do it this way it's like
no you don't like the conventions are
just conventions it's just things that
people agree to but they're not set in
stone right there's a lot of room for
making the video yeah
yeah i was interviewing a chap called
matthew dix yesterday and he was talking
about you know the idea that
you know in the world there are some
people who are rule breakers and some
people who are rule followers now the
rule followers feel this sense of like i
must follow the rules and generally a
rule breaker someone who was once a rule
follower who then broke a rule
accidentally or on purpose and realized
nothing bad happened and then you get
then you see the matrix you're like wait
a minute all rules are basically made up
and unless like the state or violence or
the police is enforcing them basically
everything is made up and therefore you
can like find the most direct path find
the positive belief resistance do the
thing and the benefit of that is that no
one else is also then doing the thing
because everyone else is a rule follower
yeah i think this comes up for me a lot
when with boundaries so when we talk
about like distractions and
interruptions a lot of it is like well i
would get so much done if i didn't have
to be in all these meetings or if my
boss wouldn't hit me up on slack or text
me all the time it's like well have you
talked to them you know do they know
what they're what's happening that you
would be able to do more deep work or
get more things done if you weren't
switching priorities all the time well
no like you know they're my boss like
well why don't you tell them why don't
you have a conversation and finding oh
not only were they really supportive of
that that problem no longer exist only
because i had the courage to speak up
that a lot of these self-perceived well
i can't do that is like well
what if you did that what's the worst
that could happen what's the best thing
that could happen
and it comes back to right there's
there's an experiment that can be done
here to disprove these assumptions that
we have about the world that really
aren't all that well-founded
nice experiments
you're a big on the whole thinking and
experiments thing your uh
pdf ebook book experiment without limits
it's great i've actually referenced it
on my other podcast with my brother a
couple of times yeah every time we need
a something to talk about i'm like you
know what let's just look up chris's pdf
and just go through some how to do
figure out what to do with your life
questions i'm the same way i was like
hey you guys want something to talk
about
so what's how how do you think about
like experiments great so yeah first the
the workbook that ali is referencing
experiment without limits it's available
for completely free online you can find
that at forcingfunction.com
workbook if you prefer the uh to you
know write things down i'm an analog guy
so i like to have it out at my desk and
write things in the book we put it for
at cost on amazon you can order it there
in any country the way that i thought
about it was i work with all these just
really smart talented ambitious people i
want to deconstruct what seems to work
for all these peak performers into a
step-by-step guide that people can
follow because a really big value for me
is open sourcing my knowledge so this is
my way of giving back is to put this out
there for free so everyone can benefit i
spent almost a year putting it together
and so i've put a lot of effort in my
mind we tried to create the best free
productivity resource on the internet
and i i think we did pretty well but the
concept of experiments why we had it in
the title why it's so near and dear to
me because i think it's getting around
this lack of action i think that so many
things in life are solved by taking
action and it's usually deconstructing
to like the smallest possible action to
get some sort of feedback about what's
working and what's not working and as
you might be able to tell listening to
me i have had the tendency to over
intellectualize things or try to over
systematize over plan over design and my
idea of framing as an experiment is well
what's an hypothesis i have what's a
guess that hey if i do x y will happen
if i start putting out youtube videos i
will start to
find my tribe i will start to have
opportunities fall on my lap whatever it
may be and find a way to test that well
what's the fastest possible path to test
this all right creating a creating
experiment around it and then seeing
what happens
so
this way
i am able to commit to something right i
give the experiment full opportunity to
work i say like all right i'm gonna do
this for
30 days if we're trying to be our 21
year old poker player i would say six
months minimum because it's gonna take
you a while to get good i commit to the
six months and i say all right what are
the signs that i'm going to see along
the way this experiment is going well if
i see these signs are going well that
i'm making progress that my inputs are
leading to good outputs how am i going
to double down how am i going to
accelerate on this and that's what
really a lot of life is is just pulling
all these levers okay a little bit a
little bit more of this a little bit
less of this i want to add something i
have to put something down so all right
working out is helping me i have more
energy okay what if i worked out a
little bit harder what if i worked out a
little bit more often that sort of thing
okay i'm going to pull this lever a
little bit
and the way i form it as an experiment
is i'm constantly collecting data
everything that i'm do i'm getting
feedback on what's working on what's not
working and the things that are working
i do more of that the things that aren't
working i do less of that hey i notice
when i do this the days feel fulfilling
and happy all right why don't i try
doing that a little bit more hey i
noticed those days that i didn't go
outside i didn't feel as good all right
i'm gonna try going outside and and
that's the thing is it takes the
pressure off of everything it's all like
okay great i'm gonna do this and see
what happens
and how much fun life becomes when you
just have a total sense of curiosity
about everything hey if i push this
button let's see what it does oh i'm
going to keep pushing that button i'm
going to keep pulling this lever so that
that's if i could kind of train one
mindset into people
is to approach things experimentally to
try it see what happens if you like the
results keep doing it
so i just had an idea for a video called
how to stop overthinking and i think
thinking
thinking in bets thinking in experiments
like i i find myself almost doing this
by default but just not intentionally
enough i think like when we moved into
the studio it was like you know what
this move to london this move to build a
team in person is a one year long
experiment we're going to try it we're
going to see what happens we're kind of
going to go all on it going to go all in
on it while we're trying it out which is
why we're in this expensive fancy studio
hey it's one year experiment we'll i'm
sure we'll learn things along the way
and we've learnt so much along the way
and it's been fun and now it's time for
the next experiment which is probably
all right cool
given that i'm going to stay in london
what does it look like to be in a studio
where it's in my house and like what if
i were to live with my brother and his
wife and that could be fun let's try
that as an experiment and see what
happens and i was thinking the other day
like what was it i was listening to like
a random noah kagan episode no i was
re-listening to the deep dive interview
i did with noah kagan like two years ago
and he said something in that about hey
you know uh i've always liked the idea
of living in a van so i'm just gonna you
know i've rented a van for three weeks
i'm just gonna try it out and i was like
[ __ ] i've always liked the idea of
living in a van but i have i have not
taken that next leap to be like you know
what let me just actually rent a van for
a week and see what it's like i've
always thought one day
when i'm five years from now when i'm in
the u.s when i've got my visa i'd like
to do a van road trip across the u.s
but actually i could just literally rent
a van in london and live in it for a
week just to see what it's like as an
experiment and then i added that to my
like list of experiments that i want to
run and i find that for me whenever i
feel well yeah whenever i'm overthinking
about something just actually telling
myself hey it's an experiment
let's
treat it even just that word just
immediately takes all the pressure off
it's great
yeah a challenge that i used to have was
just facing existential inks all the
time it's like hey is the thing that i'm
doing with my life the thing that i
actually want to do and i found this all
right okay i'm going to commit to this
for this amount of time and for that
amount of time i'm just going to give it
my best shot i'm going to try my best
that way i have no regrets and at the
end of the month the three months the
six months i'll say all right i can stop
doing that and do something completely
else if i want all right so how did that
go what aspects did i love about what
aspects did i not like so much what went
well what didn't go well and from that i
take off all of these days in the middle
of like hey is this thing that i'm doing
the thing i actually want to do with my
life like look not time for that i'm
still running the experiment still
running the experiment and that's the
thing is i've set aside the time to take
a step back and say i can do literally
whatever i want with my life what do i
want to do but i want to be asking that
question every single day i want it to
be in its designated time before and
after the experiment so there's a real
power in this commitment because a
challenge or opportunity that we have is
that life has unlimited optionality but
if we're just bouncing all these options
all the time we're totally like that
meme like we instead of looking in front
of the person from person right in front
of us we're like turning around and like
oh well i could be talking to that
person i could be talking to that person
so by committing all right for the next
year i'm going to prioritize having the
studio and see what that's like and
after the year i can decide whether i
want a studio or not
that has a lot of power because that
full year you're giving the experiment
the full time to run yeah and you're
also freeing up your own mental
bandwidth to be constantly revisiting
that decision like i'm just thinking
yeah again again to use a youtube for
example one of our friends when she
started her youtube channel about 18
months ago her name's elizabeth he was
like you know what i'm gonna commit to
this thing i've watched all these videos
where he says two videos a week oh he
says one video a week for two years she
was like i don't think i'm very good so
it's like all right cool let's make it
two videos a week for four years and
that's going to be the period of my
experiment and then i'll and then i'm
not gonna i'm like once i've committed
to it i'm not gonna think about it
anymore and it just just sort of
committing to that decision almost like
you know i ventured to say committing to
the decision to marry someone it's like
cool
i have tied myself up from i have tied
myself off as it were from the
optionality that's out there in the
market
great like now i can fully focus on this
person
one thing you mentioned was this bias
this propensity that we have to pat
ourselves on the back i wonder if we can
zoom in on that like what do you what do
you mean by that it seems to me that
it's very tempting
to
justify our own behavior in investing
they have this this saying eat well or
sleep well
that any improvement that you make to
your investing returns that you make
more money generally comes with more
stress
you're making more decisions you're
watching the markets more closely so
there's a real luxury to being hands off
to sleeping well but that luxury comes
at the cost is you're you're probably
not on it as much right you're not as
you're not as on top of things so that's
one of the key trade-offs is like all
right you can't be completely passive
about anything
so any level of being active is going to
bring some level of stress anxiety and
effort
so a lot of the temptation in psychology
we call this status quo bias is hey
everything that i'm doing right now is
pretty great i'm just going to keep on
doing that and i see this a lot when i
lead workshops around a quarterly or
annual review where people's goals tend
to be i'm going to do exactly all the
things that i was just doing plus 20
so all those things i was going to do
i'm going to put up you know 20 more
pounds on the bench press i'm going to
write 20 more articles i'm going to sell
20
more packages and you know
like well okay great like where's that
where are all those 20 is going to come
from like what are the things that
you're no longer doing this is like this
like same but more tendency and so a
better way that i think about doing is
like i use another investment analogy
imagine that you sold all of your
investments and now you're just sitting
on a pile of cash or
all of your commitments all of your your
job your classes all the things you're
doing you're no longer doing you look at
your calendar and it's completely open
for the next year okay what do you do
with that time
it's like our bias is to justify the
things that we're already doing let's
say okay i'm just going to keep on doing
more than that but it's like realization
you could do anything what do you do
with that i think is a much better place
to operate from because naturally
just to you know
sleep well we tell ourselves hey what
i'm doing is great
but we get all our identity tied up and
like all right if i'm if i'm being
successful then i'm a success if i'm if
i'm doing really well then i'm a good
person like i'm happy all sides of
things versus like
i
am separate from what i do i am not what
i do
given that i am separate what do i
choose to do
i think this like this
separation of identity is real important
to be able to take an objective look at
ourselves and say what are the things
that are doing right that i'm doing
right now what are things that are
happening that i think could be going
better what are some things actions that
i could take it doesn't mean that i'm
not doing well i'm doing great but here
are some ways that things be going even
better i think this is a real hack for
objectivity another way is to
imagine
that you're giving advice to a friend
and the friend is in the exact situation
that you're in what's the obvious advice
that you would tell your friend it's
very easy to see from the outside but if
you try to give that advice to
yourselves like well i already tried
that or i can't do that it's like well
what would you tell a friend there's all
of these ways to just be a little bit
more objective about what we're doing
and
this is big for me as i'm always trying
to correct for my natural bias another
one that i like a lot is fear is a
compass so if i'm between two options
always do the thing that's scarier
because naturally i'm gonna shy away
from the thing that i'm afraid of so if
i think i should do it but i'm not sure
and it's really scary then i should
definitely do it
and all this type of stuff is just
coming through
this planning experimentation reflecting
process of like what are the things that
i've learned what how am i going to when
i'm facing this type of decision in the
future you know how do i want to make
this decision as everything that goes
out into eternity i'm thinking about
what's my process going to be how can i
improve this process for the future
um
yeah i think i think i fall into the
status quo bias quite a lot one thing
you and i were sort of just briefly
touched on on the walk here was i did
this odyssey plan thing where it's like
hey what's your what does your life look
like for the next five years it's like
cool now throw that out
start from scratch like from your from
your current point what does your life
look like for the next five years uh
five years from now if you took a
completely different path and then cool
that's fine now start again what does
your life look like five years from now
if
you took a completely different path
again and if uh money and status were no
longer concerns
and when i did this exercise a few weeks
a couple months ago and posted in my
newsletter all three options ended up
in one way or another
i am creating content on the internet
and now like part of me was like
i i saw that and i was like hmm
is this a sign that this is what i meant
to be doing that i really fundamentally
value teaching and stuff and this is the
way i'm doing it
or more likely is this just a failure of
imagination where i'm so tied up i've
got the blinders so on with like i'm a
youtuber with three million subscribers
in a podcast i need to create content on
the internet
where that i'm not even
entertaining any possible life beyond
that because
again it i i think it comes down to i
was kind of feeling this about a year
ago about a year ago i was toying with
the idea of doing an mba in the us or
something and what my brother was saying
to me was like look you've got this
infinite sort of degree in infinite
degrees of options around you
and you're picking the options that seem
most legible which in your current life
means either being a youtuber or going
to university and doing a degree or
going back to medicine which are like
the only three routes in life that i
have ever had experience with how should
i help tackle my status quo bias in this
sense it's it's a really difficult
question to ask because i think it
really
gets at things that i can only
guess at from my observations of you
which is you know what what do you value
most in life
i think you're right and that
creating content on the internet being a
commonality could both be a signal that
this is a true calling for you and just
a failure of imagination or a
fear of doing something that you're
unproven in that you know who knows how
it could work out it's really hard to
say so that's why i'm always asking
questions like you know what do you like
about what you're doing right now what
do you not like so much about you doing
what would you do more if you could if
you had an extra hour in your day yeah
how would you ask that
because i find that the best proxy on
someone's values is there is their
behavior
so getting at these sort of
hypotheticals like if you could do
anything what would you do and working
from okay what are the commonalities and
the things that you would do without
these constraints in place that's why
it's really hard to make
universals like hey this is what a good
life looks like because for me a good
life comes back to values like
do you understand what you value because
these change and shift over time it's
this like
infinite process of excavation
and once you have a good understanding
of that or at least a provincial
understanding of that
does your is your life a reflection of
that of living in alignment with that so
i know for you
that making videos on the internet
satisfies a lot of deep values you know
teaching giving back it's an engine for
personal growth
um and the question is always like great
like what does that you know when you're
doing something questions like what does
that bring you right so example
someone's like all right what do you
want it's like i want a million dollars
okay what does a million dollars bring
you what does that unlock what what what
can you do with a million dollars that
you can't do now and you start to get
okay well i can provide for my family or
oh i can take that class i always wanted
or i could have a space to create my art
whatever it is okay so now we know what
you're going at directly let's try to
find that most direct path there so okay
you want to teach people for example
what are other ways that you could be
doing that that you could satisfy that
value and that gets around this like
this is the only thing that i could be
doing to all right now that i understand
what i'm trying to achieve what are
other things that i could do that are
presumably towards that and then you can
start to frame an experiment you see
okay maybe it's a thing that i just
really like teaching so why don't i try
teaching another format and see
what i like what i don't like about that
and see it all goes back to try
something see what works do a little bit
more of that
see it doesn't work when i think about
this in a productivity sense it's always
like you know once i understand what i
want to do what brings me happiness and
fulfillment how can i make that easier
to do how can i make that more of a
commonality in my life the things that
get in the way it's like well you know
watching watching watching netflix is
fun you know i like i like film i think
it's really interesting i think being
culture is very cool but i could be
doing other things instead that i seem
to enjoy more than bring me more
fulfillment so how do i make netflix a
little bit harder to access it's not
that netflix is not as bad it's just not
as good for me
so it's like you can see this ladder is
like what do i value what are things
that i do to seem to satisfy their
values how do i make those things that
seem to satisfy those values more
accessible in my life more of a
recurring presence so many ideas for
experiments that i want to run one
hypothesis i've had about my life is
that i think i seem to value kind of
social social connection with people
like a lot of people do unsurprisingly
um and i was like okay cool one
hypothesis was that like therefore
living with a flatmate is going to be
more fun for me than living alone but to
be honest i've never really tried the
living alone experiment so i should just
run that experiment for a week or two i
mean i've tried it for a couple of weeks
here and there in the pandemic and like
it was fine but like that that could be
an experiment i try but another thing i
want to do is like i know i enjoy
hanging out with friends a lot and i
know enjoy hosting people at my place
but it's a lot of
effort to clean afterwards and stuff and
as i'm saying that i'm thinking okay i
mean paper plates solves that problem a
bin bag solves that problem ordering
pizza rather than trying to cook solve
that problem hiring a private chef for a
night just to see what happens and just
be like that might be a fun thing to do
invite like 10 friends over get a
private chef to cook for everyone and
clean up afterwards all of these are
experiments that i absolutely could run
and should run to be like hey this
this will actually make it easier for me
to satisfy the value of i enjoy
connecting with people and having people
over at my place
yeah this brings me to the concept of
over optimization i feel like this is
something that someone else besides me
needs to hear is there's an assumption
that hey if i'm going to do something i
need to do it all out or it's not worth
doing at all so for example it's like i
love travel we're having this
conversation because i'm traveling
around europe and i especially love
creating experiences for my friends i
love planning group trips i love hosting
i love planning events and doing things
like that but because i can have
perfectionistic tendencies because like
everything has levels and i always want
to try to raise the bar somehow i'll
create situations where for example i'm
planning a birthday trip right now it's
like all right i need to just be like
four days like packed non-stop like top
of the line experiences and i found
myself wow i'm putting a lot of thought
and effort into this that i could be
doing other things and like starting to
get a little bit worried like well what
if it doesn't match my expectations and
realizing people aren't coming to my
birthday trip because they want the trip
of a lifetime at least i i don't think
so because they want to celebrate me
meet my friends like have a nice weekend
and i'm realizing all right if what i'm
doing this for what i'm optimizing for
is to bring people together for a nice
experience what are all of these
cherries on top that i'm putting like
way too much time and attention into all
right come thinking back to all right
what i value most is this sense of
connection and bringing people together
who should meet and like having like a
michelin star chef cook every meal and
like go on these like super logistically
complicated excursions like it's a nice
to have but it's not a need to have
right so it's like as you were talking
coming back to all right what am i
trying to achieve here what about what
am i valuing what is the most direct
path towards just like bringing people
together in the room yeah i so i did a
kind of party thing at my place a couple
months ago for my for my birthday
and this was my first time kind of
hosting a lot of people in one big room
and stuff and i was quite like frazzled
about like the food situation and like
ah there wasn't enough this wasn't
enough that and like ah and no one
notices all that stuff yeah so like a
a friend of mine kind of could see that
i was a bit like frazzled and he was
like okay i'm going to say something to
you i know i also need to hear more
often take a breath
when you're 85 years old you're gonna
give anything to be back here and enjoy
this moment in the present day and also
no one gives a [ __ ] about the food so
just relax enjoy yourself people are
here they're having a good time don't
worry about it and i was like
he's so right and i was still sort of
worrying about the food in the back of
my mind but then i was thinking who
cares the berries ran out the yogurt ran
out
who actually cares like the point was
that people were there and i think
this like for me as well i i put a lot
of like if if i'm doing this it should
be done right and if i'm doing this i
don't just wanna hold a pizza i'm
actually ordering pizza super easy i
should just order pizza if if the
requirement for me to cook is it going
to stop me from hanging out with friends
screw screw cooking just like inviting
my pizza like get people over encourage
that social connection more
this is a mental reframe that's been
really impactful for me just kind of the
way that my brain work is i'm just hyper
active like hyper aware of opportunities
and opportunities for improvement in
particular like this thing is great but
like oh if i did this it'd be more
streamlined if i did this it would
change the lighting if i change oh like
if i position the food in this way if i
put the bar over here the flow will be
better like always like thinking about
the next one right that's like the
downside of the process orientation
always thinking about how the process
could be better and take the step back
and breathe and enjoy it's like oh like
all my friends are here let's let's
enjoy this and have fun we can do a
post-mortem after the event but it's
turning what can become
an obligation into an opportunity
right i think about something like a
to-do list
you think a lot the way that a lot of
people treated to-do list is here's this
like never-ending list of obligations
that i have to get through before i can
have fun and it's this morbid thought
that we're going to die with a very long
to-do list because we're going to keep
adding things to it and if our whole
goal is to get through the list until we
can be happy and enjoy ourselves like
we're in for not so good of a time so
the way i try to always reframe is like
this is not my list of to do's this is
not an obligation that i've thrown upon
my shoulders but all opportunities these
are all things that i don't need to do
any of these but i could do them and
maybe things will be going even better
and that's always a frame is like
i'm great i don't need to do anything
but here's here's some things that i
could do which one of these like do i
want to do now it's very subtle from
like oh i have to plan this party now i
have to send out all these invites okay
i have to figure out you know oh i have
all these dietary restrictions i have to
communicate with the chef he's like
planning a party like having a good time
with your friends easy can be like a
to-do list to like wow what a great
opportunity to bring my friends together
to create this element of surprise and
serendipity and wonder that we can all
be in this shared container and have a
good time it's like well like do i
really care that much about the food
maybe i don't or maybe it's like oh this
is a cool opportunity to try to make a
new dish or to like try a new skill it's
just that that subtle frame not only
makes everything we're doing more fun it
allows it to be more present in the and
like harvest the benefits of the things
we're doing too yeah one thing i was
thinking as as you were describing that
the the this there's this tendency that
oh i'll write this down my thing the
tendency to overthink about stuff and
the perfectionistic tendencies and i
always get this question in our youtube
academy live sessions and the thing i
always say is that and i should take my
advice on this in other areas of life
which is that
look it's all well and good overthinking
about your production value and your
lighting and your sound and stuff but
don't let any of that stop you from
publishing the video as long as you are
hitting that consistent schedule of
whatever you've decided it is once a
week twice a week whatever it might be
as long as you're putting the videos out
overthink all you like but don't let
that stop you from putting the putting
the videos out and i think as you know
with my channel and with our team as
we've grown the team and as we've had to
evolve elaborate processes for doing
things
at the times when that has come at the
expense of our upload schedule the
channel is slumped and not done very
well at the time they were like well
we're fixing the processes but like the
videos does the vid the videos are still
coming out
then everything has felt like it's
moving way more forward
and as i'm saying this i'm thinking that
like okay if i i've kind of had a goal
for the since january when i did my new
year's goals like hey i'd like to have
people over for dinner every week i have
people over there nowhere near as
frequently as every week but if i just
set aside like friday nights am i having
having people over dinner time and it
almost became a thing where it's like at
the very least i need to invite at least
one person over on friday and then
beyond that i can start stacking up oh
let's try the chef let's try the pizza
let's try cooking let's try this but
it's all on the fundamental layer of hey
the the main point is to just hang out
with my friends a bit more there's this
concept in economics called revealed
preferences
that what people tell you they believe
is much different from what they
actually believe or how they act how
they believe yeah and productivity
context is if you ask someone hey what's
important to you the answer will be very
different from how they act what's
important to them yeah so a very early
thing that i do with the clients is i
have them share with me their calendar
and beforehand i know like what their
top values are what they say their goals
are what their priorities are and i have
a very clear side by side saying well
hey like you said that like your biggest
goal for the quarter is making this new
hire or raising this investment round
but i look at your calendar and i don't
see it anywhere on there so like which
one is it is it not a priority for you
or is it you're just not prioritizing it
and that's what really we talk about
prioritization that it is is like
understanding what's most important and
putting that first yeah right so it's
very easy to pick a goal for example i'm
gonna have friends over every week and
just be like okay great let's do it it's
gonna happen but then it's like okay
well if i want to have friends over
every week like what does that mean well
it means i need to set aside a week
every night i need to have a plan for
that i need to be inviting out far
enough in advance for people to come
over and it's like essentially like what
do i need to give up in order for this
to happen
and a lot of people don't take those
extra steps they're just like set the
goal and be okay we'll figure it out
along the way it's like if it's really a
priority what does that mean what do you
have to stop doing in order for that to
happen so that's like a big thing that
i'm always trying to see is like how can
my schedule be more perfection of my
goals of my priorities and that's the
same thing the inverse is true it's like
what am i dedicating time and resources
to that's not on my goal list it's not a
priority list because like when you ask
someone okay what are you going to stop
doing it's like well i have to do all
these things well this thing it's not a
goal of yours not a top priority why are
you doing that
okay well
which is true is it more important or is
it not a fun
very painful exercise that gets everyone
to love me very much is i have everyone
list all of their priorities it's like
you know a bunch of brainstorm okay what
what are you doing with your health what
are you doing with your career we're
doing your relationship all those things
out people have these i'm like how many
things you got on your list are like 10
12 26 it's like awesome that's so great
you have so many things going on okay i
want you to number these in order now
like 1 2 5 10 25 26 okay great i'm
numbering okay this one's not quite as
important but they're like okay now i
know all right i'm going to do these
like all these 26 things and then do
them in these words like well no
i want you to go through the bottom half
of your list and cross a line through
them
so say you got 10 things on your list
these are your 10 goals for the quarter
okay now you have five goals every time
you try to bring up you made progress on
goal six through ten i'm just going to
cut you off and say okay well what are
you doing towards goals one through five
like those are the important ones right
because the biggest distractions are
working on the things that we can
justify later but are not our top
priorities right it's the opportunity
cost
so this is something that if you don't
correct for is really really insidious
again thinking about our tendency of
justifying everything we're doing is
good a client will show up for a call
and like okay like what's happened since
last call and they share a bunch of
updates it's like hey i talked to this
person oh this thing happens like oh i
don't see that on any of your goals is
that that's really interesting what
updates do you have related to these
goals be like oh well you know like it
was really busy all these things happen
it's like okay so what you're saying is
that those things were more of a
priority well no no no it's really funny
when you have to kind of walk back and
justify your behavior it's like okay
well is it a priority or is it not a
priority
and again like zero judgment maybe you
decided along the way okay maybe i don't
need to have friends over for dinner
every week or maybe you just haven't
treated it as a priority but this is a
opportunity for a reflection and it's
like you have this regular feedback
right the more often that you're
checking in closing this loop iterating
the more quickly can adjust so let's say
you had part of weekly review one of
your questions is like did i have
friends over for dinner this week and
you're like no and it gets marked yellow
and the next week like did i have
friends over dinner the week and like no
it's like oh two weeks in a row that's a
red and that that becomes like a canary
in the coal mine a signal it's like all
right well two weeks in a row i said i
was going to do this thing and didn't do
this thing clearly what i'm doing is not
working so first checking in is this
still important to me that's always the
first question is like you can always
decide later don't want to do this and
say well actually yes i do want to have
friends over a week so then it's just
like what is one thing that i'm going to
do
this week as an experiment that might
work to make this happen it's like okay
well i never set out invites so now i'm
gonna set aside a time when i send out
some invites i'm gonna set a date and
you try it and you see what happens and
that way even if it's a no in week
number three you're like all right i
tried it that didn't work is this still
important to me what am i going to try
next and that way you catch it and you
iterate more more often and that the
thing that you said was a priority
actually gets treated as a priority yeah
i i it's so funny there that you said
this when you said that line um
is this thing not a priority or are you
just not prioritizing it it's literally
word for word what my editor said to me
last week when i actually did two weeks
ago and i was like yeah so just like
yeah so how was progress on the book
this week and i was like yeah you know
stuff came up
um and she was like okay let's let's
think about this she was super nice
about it but she was like you know it
seems that this bookish thing is a
priority for you if it's not then you
know that's a different conversation and
that's fine we can talk about it but if
it is it sounds like you're not
prioritizing the thing that you say is
your number one priority and i was like
damn you're right and then she was like
okay what can we try as an experiment
this week
perhaps she's worked with you sounds
like yeah yeah and i was like okay cool
we can try that okay
non-negotiable three hours in the
morning to do the thing we can try i
don't really get work done at home so
i'll go to the local uh restaurant to do
it we can try that we can try i will say
i'll write clocking in on slack in our
book slack channel whenever i'm getting
started on the book stuff we can try
i'll post screenshots of what i'm
working on so i have accountability and
all those things worked really well and
i've made progress on the book so much
in the last like seven days than i have
in like the month before i guess yeah
one question i have is one touching that
real first
it's it's so obvious that it's it
doesn't even feel worth stating but we
act as if it's not true is there can
only be one top priority
we like to act as like there's a bunch
of top priorities but like there's only
one top priority and by definition if
it's your top priority it's a
non-negotiable everything else fits
around it the classic annoying analogy
of your filling your jar like the top
priority is the giant boulder that you
put into the jar and then everything
else is just sand that fits around it so
if example i keep using your examples
that you keep so generously putting out
there if writing the book is the top
priority it comes first it means it gets
its own block in the morning and then
other things happen if there's time yeah
but the way that we treat a lot of these
things that are called important but not
urgent
is that they happen when it's convenient
for us when we have time when we're not
busy when there's not other things going
on we don't have deadlines and so i
always say like put the important but
not urgent first the urgent things will
always happen but instead we like try to
treat it try to like fill the jar and
then like stick a boulder in there
so
i'm always trying to think about all
right if this is really most important
to me what does that mean we come back
to values
i have clients who say for example that
family is my top value the obvious
follow-up is okay if if family is most
important to you family is your top
priority what does that look like for
you means okay and again there's no
right answers to this it could be we sit
down for dinner every night it means
that like my kids get an hour of
undivided attention before bed it's like
hey you know weekends i'm completely off
no work whatever it means to them okay
this is what it means to have type
priority okay and the obvious follow-up
question is like what do you need to do
for this to be the case like what gets
in the way of being able to sit down for
dinner with your family or having the
weekends off and everything comes back
to that is like if it's really most
important
what else needs to conform around it
what else needs to get out of the way
because the way that we like to do it is
like well it it really is important to
me but all these other things came up
and it's just life just doesn't work
like that so we've kind of talked about
this sort of meandering you mentioned
you how you have clients and stuff but
like uh i was i was going to mention
this in the intro that i record after
the fact that you are a performance
coach and you and i actually worked
together are you or my performance coach
for three months about 18 months ago and
it was great what does a performance
coach do and i guess how did you become
one and
i guess the the question i want to
follow up on that is that like if
someone in the audience listens to this
decides as a 21 year old i too want to
become a performance coach what is what
is the process of doing this as a side
hustle look like oh man uh well as far
as what a performance coach does i think
you could probably answer this better
than i could being on the other side the
way that i try to describe it is
i act as a third party objective
observer for high performers to
accelerate their path towards their
goals so what that generally looks like
is asking lots of annoying questions
like is this really a priority okay what
are you doing towards that what's the
next step what are you committed to
doing this week those types of things
so there's a there's a hybrid of you
know holding someone's feet to the fire
the classic accountability type stuff
there's acting as this mirror for what's
really important to you what's really
working for you there's taking some of
my
systems thinking lens and thinking how
all right this thing you want to be
doing regularly how can we make that
more consistent less effortful for you
get more out of it these types of things
it really depends upon the clients and
their goals
but the commonality that i see is that
someone comes out of the process with
more clarity on their goals and what's
more important what's important to them
that feels like the things they're going
after they're the process is easier
they're getting
more of the things they'd like to
done you know more things less time
classic
but it's
primarily about doing the right things
the things that are actually moving the
needle actually a priority to them align
with their top values
and then just really a sense of how this
can be a repeatable process something
that goes on
beyond our work together right my
typical agreement i only work with 12
clients at a time and it's usually in
three month sprints so i i always wanted
to be like the trainer who like gave the
whole playbook at the first class and
said okay go forth and do it and i think
a lot of that comes down to some of
these principles and mindsets that i've
tried to share today which these things
are really grounded in action so it all
comes back to me for experiments and we
co-create an experiment say hey
say this is a top priority for you for
the next quarter what would that look
like convert then to some sort of input
goal so okay so you're saying
you know every day you want to spend the
first hour of your day meditating or the
first hour of your day writing or you
want to host a party at your place every
week what is what are the what are the
actions that you need to take in order
to make this happen let's say you're
successful let's work backwards from
that let's say that you didn't achieve
this well would be some reasons why you
didn't reasons that you failed so kind
of simulating ahead of time so we don't
have to learn through experience and
then we try it and as we work together
we try things we see what works we
double down on that so i see myself as
primarily a guide where i think a lot of
my clients have a pretty good idea of
what works but always the interesting
question is well you know this works why
aren't you doing it and that's that's
where all the really interesting
conversations happen
yeah there's a i think i i heard one
time around around the idea of coaching
and executive coaching because basically
everyone seems to have a coach of some
sort and people who don't have a coach
are always like what the hell does a
coach do like why the hell do you need a
coach
and it's like
in a way like the less you pay for a
coach the more tactical the advice is
or something like that where it's like
when you're in the sort of i don't know
i have a tennis coach or something like
that it's like a very specific thing
that you're working on whereas as you
get to the higher and higher levels i
suspect roger federer's tennis coach is
not really teaching him about four hands
and it's a lot about psychology and the
mind and like
behavior and emotions and dealing with
his own like traumas and it becomes
almost like a
i find any time i've worked with a coach
it sort of felt more like what i imagine
a therapist would be rather than what i
initially imagined a coach would be does
that kind of vibe with your experience
every client is different i think that
mental game is is really important when
i think about mental game it's the some
of the psychological mindset
preparedness
showing up presents that type of stuff
that i think is really important for
high performance in any endeavor i think
i think there's always
this
toeing the line of i think it's very
different from therapy but clearly
people find ways to
act out old patterns mental and
otherwise to
get in their own way to
you know prevent success so there's
usually an aspect of taking a step back
and looking at past behavior and
identifying hey what are the patterns
that we want to repeat maybe the
patterns that we want to disrupt
but
the main differential again experience
of one that i would have between you
know my therapist and myself is i want
everything that we talk about to be
quantifiable
and that hey we are we have set
milestones and metrics towards a goal
and my job is to
support you
in making the progress towards the thing
that you've said is important to you
yeah you have conversations about if
it's important why it's important what
is the path what is that road map but at
the end of the day if we ensure that
regular steps are being taken towards
that we have some raw material to work
with right i think when you're thinking
about talking to
an employee or just auditing yourself is
it like is it that i'm not putting in
the effort like a failure to prioritize
as we were saying before or that the
things that i'm doing aren't working and
there's always those two passes like
well is this not a priority for you okay
you are putting in efforts but the
efforts that you're doing aren't leading
you to the specific goal that you want
so let's try something else let's see if
this perhaps we step back we change the
approach we can have different results
so those are those are the types of
conversations that i have again i think
i think your point about
tactical versus more psychological is
really apt is if you want someone to
teach you how to use notion for example
it's pretty pretty prescriptive very
step-by-step if you want someone again
this is just one example of like okay
well
why aren't you using your notion system
to
save your notes and is this really
though it's what's in the way of you not
publishing your book or is there
something deeper that's going on and
that you're not setting aside the time
or you don't know what to write about
all these types of things
that starts to get into things that are
much more bespoke
and we're drawing on experience of i
mean having worked with you know over
100 clients at this point you start to
see the same patterns occur
so that's kind of the answer to
how does one start doing it is you just
do it i think fortunately or
unfortunately i just love teaching so i
just can't help doing it and i'm luckily
i've found a societally acceptable you
know great way to you know find this
outlet and you know have a little bit of
impact on people at least they tell me
so is okay well
both this seems to work generally for
most people you know wake up do the most
important thing don't check your email
uh all that sort of stuff but also from
past experience and from what you told
me these things seem to work really well
for you why don't we go back to doing
that that's like the coaching cheat code
by the way is like hey that time that
things were going really well for you
what were you doing okay why don't you
try doing that again like we always want
to try doing something new but we
generally we already know the thing
that's working so yeah breaking down
this like third party objective observer
third party i'm outside i'm not invested
i want your success but i don't really
care how you succeed objective i'm
trying to bring some objectivity towards
it's like hey this is what you're
telling me this is what i'm seeing this
is what seems to work and like observer
hey that's really interesting tell me
more about that or like i'm not quite
sure like you say this is important to
you but it doesn't look like it's
important to you talk to me about that
that's that's the role that i type to
try to play and you know the world calls
the executive coach so that's what i go
with hmm let's say again we've got our
21 year old in the audience they're like
i've got a job i kind of want to make
money on the side
becoming a coach sounds like a good idea
anyone can call themselves a coach these
days why don't i become a life coach oh
executive coach that sounds like
basically being a life coach but you can
charge more because it's got the word
executive on it how would you advise
said 21 year old we can roll plate if
you like or however however however you
would kind of advise this person to
explore this as a potential side hustle
that which could potentially become a
full-time living further down the line
yeah i'm gonna generalize this to
starting any business is generally if
you're trying to make money from
something right assuming that your goal
to coach is to make money from it and
there can be lots of other tangential
goals but let's say you're trying to
create a coaching business or any
business it's well what is the feedback
that someone has given you it's like oh
you're really good at doing this oh what
if you offered this i bet i would pay
you for that or like man like every i
had that conversation with you you
really sorted me on it like listening to
this type of feedback or people saying
like you what you are doing here you're
both good at it and it is useful this is
this is good feedback to receive if
you're not receiving any of this type of
feedback this is an anti-signal that hey
perhaps this is not something that you
should be doing i think there's a sense
that
people who get really good at something
they can't help but doing it not saying
they're naturally good at it but it's
something they're naturally curious
about and they just can't help talking
about it and doing it with people
so
i part of the reason that i think i've
been able to become better as a coach i
think i'm you never quite arrive at like
i've figured it all out is that i'm just
very very curious about people and i'm
very interested in what seems to lead to
success and happiness and fulfillment
and this is just a really effective
avenue for me to scratch my own itch
yeah yeah i i think it's kind of similar
for me in the sense that like from like
the age of seven i have enjoyed
explaining stuff to people in my class
and then from the age of like 13 to 20 i
was a private tutor teaching people
maths and english from the age of like
17 through to 25 i was teaching courses
to help kids get into medical school
from like 18 to 24 i was teaching
medical students younger than me how to
and so like at every stage of my life
i've just found myself drawn to teaching
people stuff whatever that stuff might
be
and so
the extension of oh let's teach stuff on
youtube
whereas before in a previous life i
tried youtube to be a musician no one's
ever told me i'm good at singing no
one's ever told me i'm good at playing
musical instruments but i said i wanted
to try it and experiment try it out but
as soon as i aligned the thing i was
doing with the thing that i was i got
like for 15 years of feedback from that
oh you're actually good at this thing
and you seem to enjoy this thing
suddenly things started to click
so i guess you know at this point
someone might be thinking oh damn i've
like no one says i'm good at anything
and i feel like i don't have any skills
that are useful to society what
what would you say to that person well i
assume we're talking to a 21 year old
and i mean it's very easy again i'm 35
to sit back and say man like i thought i
knew everything but i didn't know
anything
is what a wonderful opportunity to like
you have a lifetime of compounding in
front of you what would you like to be
good at you know i think of this as like
stepping back to the meta level of we
can decide what to prioritize we can
decide what we want out of life what do
you want to want to prioritize is like
you can you can pretty much do anything
at this point and the stakes are very
low
so
if you're the younger you are thinking
about what are the things that benefit
from a lifetime of compounding
building an audience is probably one of
those building many skills particularly
interpersonal skills skills of you know
personal organization and management of
capturing and sharing ideas these are
things that tend to build upon
themselves and the good place to start
is like what are the things that you're
already really interested in it's this
classic notion that tomorrow's companies
is today's tinkering around the garage
like what's the thing that you can't
help but doing don't worry about tr like
oh it's not a job it's not something i
make a living from it just keep doing
that and particularly finding ways to
share what you're doing with others like
naturally opportunities will emerge
i tend to think that a lot of
opportunities are at the intersections
we worry all the time it's like oh i'm
about i'm the same same as everyone else
but really it's like you are the only
person with your unique set of skills
and experiences there's going to come
some sort of intersection like you found
like medicine and content creation for
me like games and investing or games and
founding companies that like i can speak
to both that very few people can right
like there's lots of people who've
played games lots of people founded
companies very few people who've done it
a high level of both there's a so
thinking about like these intersections
that will naturally emerge by just
optimizing for what's interesting to you
and i really think it's like it sounds
weird to say but like taking some of the
pressure off is just like keep doing
what you're doing and if something's
working do a little bit more of that
yeah i think it's this idea that if
you're as long as you're taking steps in
a direction that is broadly aligned with
a thing that you actually want then
something good will probably happen
further down the line yeah it's
often said but i thoroughly take it to
heart is trusting the process the main
thing to optimize for is continuous
improvement
nice so we've got our 21 year old
they've been told you know what you know
when i have a conversation with you i
feel i feel quite inspired i feel like
you know
maybe you could become a coach i've
heard people can become coaches like
what would be the next step that they
would take to set up this hypothetical
coaching business i actually want to
take a step back on this one just to i
think it's always very easy to be
sitting on our pedestal here it's like
well i've got it all figured out and
you're 21 you don't know anything so i
would like to share a little bit about
where i was at 21 yeah you know i i had
some level of
let's let's call it like cultural
success i was already making money in
poker i you know had extremely good
grades like i was you know most likely
to succeed change the world all that
sort of stuff like people like oh this
guy is like smart he's going places but
like internally i felt like a total
imposter so i graduated i moved up to
detroit um i was sort of on this like
hiring leave while i waited for the auto
industry and the economy to get their
ish together
and
i didn't see anyone like i just sat
inside for weeks the only person i would
see
was the guy who was delivering my pizza
and my two liter of soda my only friends
were on the internet nothing wrong with
that but i certainly was lacking for
social interaction really you know just
unhappy but didn't understand that i was
unhappy or understand why
and you know i was playing playing this
game but it just felt like an escape for
me
and you know it's very easy to say that
there was like this one moment where i
had the proverbial gun to my head and my
entire life turned around but really it
was just like a set of realizations that
like well
everything that i'm doing is a choice
like what if i made other choices i
could do i could do other things and you
know starting to realize well
i'm playing this game poker i'm pretty
good at it but what if i was even better
at that what would that what would that
look like well you know falling asleep
in the middle of a poker session
probably isn't helping me what if i
improve my energy levels i start
sleeping in more regular hours and i
actually go into the gym for the first
time in my life and i learn about
nutrition then maybe eating a pizza
every day especially when you're lactose
intolerant isn't the best thing to be
doing
and it's not that like i was
really really into nutrition and
performance and sleep it's like well
i want to be one of the best poker
players in the world
well what are the other best poker
players in the world doing okay well if
i want this goal i want to do that too
like saying if i want to be a cognitive
athlete i needed to be a physical
athlete so treating myself as someone
who was important as someone who was
doing something important and everything
really started to turn around from that
it's like well my energy levels are
better i can start i start making better
decisions i start making better
decisions my my life goes better oh i
start making more money i can do more
things i have more opportunities i start
creating this positive spiral and i'm
not saying that anyone here is like
not doing it or like doesn't have it but
it really all just starts with this
decision to like i'm going to try to get
a little bit better today i'm going to
try to do something
small to move towards my goals and just
every day i got a little bit closer to
all right i want to be one of the best
poker players in the world what's that
next thing that i have to do so i could
have done anything i mean i was like oh
what if i i don't think my singing voice
is particularly good but hey maybe i
want to be a broadway singer all right
what does that look like i probably need
to be training my voice i need to be
thinking about performance on a stage
all this type of stuff but like just
having the goal to go after the goal
itself isn't that much more important
than just a direction to head
so we're talking about this this 21 year
old self like not needing to have it
figured out but have a general direction
like what's something that's important
to you that you want to accomplish and
just be taking regular steps towards it
i think that it seems to me
like success like what like you have to
be making it has just gotten younger and
younger i mean this is weird from
someone who's like had his career peak
at age 23 to say but like you have all
the time in the world there was this one
moment where
you know i i retired from poker and i
was sitting on a beach in barcelona
saying like
wow have i just like had my life peak at
age 23 like what am i gonna do
now it's like is everything else just
gonna be
downhill from here and i'm just going to
be like one of those child actors just
like hoping to like you know celebrate
my big moment once again and realize oh
like
i have a lifetime do other things let's
see what those other things look like
so yeah that that's a few of the ways
that i've
thought about it and with the benefit of
whenever i'm having a conversation like
this in the back of my mind it's you
know what are the things that i would
have liked my younger self to hear
it's not it never comes down to like oh
you should try harder or do more it's
just like trust the process and you'll
get there yeah that was something i
wanted to i wanted to bring up from
something we discussed previously this
idea of so we all have this bias towards
the status quo where let's say i'm
watching netflix for three hours a night
and i'm convincing myself that like
actually actually this is a good
decision my life is going fine otherwise
i'm good and actually this three hours
is good for self-care and it makes me
happy et cetera et cetera now
some people would say that
there's a lot of time you're wasting
three hours of your life like when
you're lying on your deathbed are you
really gonna be glad that you spent
those three hours etc watching netflix
and then that person might think okay
fine maybe i'll only do two hours
netflix and one hour of like something
more productive but that can often look
like trying harder i.e doing more or
like working harder and then there's a
regret people also have of like i wish i
hadn't worked so hard so it's like how
how do you think about this balance
between i guess almost and i kind of
wrote down here sort of a spectrum of
minor but like ambition and happiness on
two other and on two ends of the
spectrum of like enjoying the and
basking in the present moment right now
and maybe going falling into the status
quo bias but actually life is pretty
good i feel day-to-day i'm pretty happy
versus
i want to be moving forward in a way
that my future self will thank me for
this is such a such a complex topic one
example that comes to mind for me i come
back to this this concept of the most
direct path i wanted to be funnier
believe it or not i think i was somewhat
successful you can be a judge of that
but i thought hey i want to be funnier
what's the most direct path to become
funnier is to perform some comedy that
through this forcing function of needing
me on stage make people laugh presumably
i'll learn a few things about the art of
making people making people laugh and
that'll translate to my conversations to
my writing to my day-to-day
well there will if i start with this
kind of abstract goal if i want to be
funnier there's lots of different things
that i could have justified towards that
goal for example i want to fire up
netflix and watch every single comedy
special on there and see what all these
comedians are doing i'm like well that
is a path but it's a very passive path
it's a very
easy going convenient path i bet if i
raise the stakes and i stand on the
stage and like
i'm actually telling the jokes as
opposed to like watching someone else
tell the jokes like oh i could do that
better i bet i would learn faster right
my feedback loop would be much tighter
and i thought this was going to be funny
and it's crickets okay let's figure that
out
so
it comes back to that question of like
yes like things are going well
but
are you on the most direct path towards
your goals
this doesn't always mean that you need
to do more or try harder sometimes that
might be true but it's more as like well
like
how is watching netflix using this
example on the path towards your goal
this is very easy to justify it is like
i'm relaxing i'm recharging i'm getting
culture etc it's like well
if you weren't watching netflix what
would you be doing with that time
instead
these are always just interesting
questions asked and perhaps the
interesting experiments to run it's like
hey what if you spent that two hours
doing something else and you see the end
of the day how do you feel about the day
what's how do you feel feel differently
just be curious about that because with
all of these things it's not that
they're good it's that are they plus ev
right yep compared to all the other
things that you could be doing
are they the best thing that you could
be doing think about things like twitter
which there's classic
upsides to using twitter but it's very
easy to hit these diminishing marginal
returns so it's not saying like is an
extra hour spent on twitter useful is
that is it more useful more eevee than
how you could spend that hour otherwise
and this doesn't need to be that like
every time you're like you know bad
chris bad ollie you you you binge that
series like you're you're a waste man
you're a failure
it's more well
uh
i watched netflix that happened i you
know no regrets it happened
but
would i want to make that decision if i
was faced with that
decision every time because that's the
thing is like these decisions that can
out in eternity every time you sit down
with your partner for a long night in
netflix you make it more likely that the
next state light is going to be another
netflix night is that what you want and
i find that stepping out from the like
rather than thinking about this
individual decision like what is the
type of decision that i'd like to make
allows me to separate out my identity
from it and i can more think about hey
well on average i like to do something
this is personal i like to do something
that's a little bit more active this
could be active learning and then i'm
doing something with my hands or i'm
having some sort of conversation
creating an artifact or it could be
actually activity and then i'm outside
with the sun in my face and i'm moving
my body for god's sakes
whatever that is and think well i want
to be more active how can i make it more
likely that i'm active in the future i
can make it easier to be active on the
same way it's like well what gets in the
way of being active well man there's
that new netflix series coming out the
algorithm is really really good at
serving me up what i could be doing well
what if i had the experiment uh but gave
away my tv for a week and i see what
happens or i sign out of my netflix
account at least i have to like remember
my password or i give my password to my
partner and i say hey i'm not allowed to
watch netflix today don't give me the
password i can't log in all these
different things you can try not that
you have to commit to forever but say
hey
let's see what happens i guess it sounds
like you know we were talking about this
the spectrum between like ambition and
happiness and stuff and actually maybe
it's kind of
strikes me as potentially a bit of a
false dichotomy kind of like i spoke to
another podcast guest greg we guessed uh
grace beverly about
the fake two sides of the spectrum
between productivity and self-care and
it's easy to convince ourselves that
actually those three hours of watching
netflix is self-care and therefore it's
good and therefore no one can possibly
argue with that because like oh my god
self-care and mental health and et
cetera et cetera et cetera and it's easy
to convince ourselves that like oh i
don't want to be one of those people
that like every day is like i'm sitting
there and hustling on my business for
three hours like screw that and it's
very easy to fall into this black and
white thinking to then justify
the lazy life choice of sitting there
and watching netflix for three hours
and i guess it sounds like
just about running the experiment what
if it was two hours one day and you
spend that hour doing something else
that works towards a goal that you have
if a goal that you have isn't to watch
everything in the netflix catalogue or
to watch every tick tock that's been
made in the last like decade yeah then
what is a goal that you have and could
you potentially even try working on that
15 minutes in that in that time because
what i find a lot of people saying you
know people in my team people on my
youtube academy people in the audience
that i speak to i fall into this pattern
myself is
we claim to have these goals and yet
when it comes to being like okay where
am i gonna where am i gonna find the
time for this we set these arbitrary
rules like oh i need three hours of
self-care each night
and it's in it's somewhat unfashionable
to say in this day and age where it's oh
my god like i couldn't possibly argue
with someone's uh lived experience of
how much self-care they need
but i always feel a bit like whenever i
find myself making up these arbitrary
rules for myself thinking that like oh i
need a dot in my life i need to spend 15
minutes in the spa after every gym
session do i really
probably not like if i didn't have it
i'd probably survive human beings have
surviving been surviving without a spa
without netflix without tick tock for
millennia like it's actually not that
hard
and i think it's very easy to convince
ourselves that that's the case i think
you're hitting on something really
valuable is that our language about how
we describe our experience can be very
revealing
so when you hear phrases like i need or
i should or i have to i think it's very
revealing about things that we're
assuming to be facts that are really
just opinions
so it is another another way of thinking
about this is the uh the opposite right
so we're worried about imperfection so
we don't put something out into the
world well what that's hiding is this
need to be perfect what's what's what's
behind that need what purpose is it
serving because there is a real purpose
the it's not that any behavior is a good
form of self-care or a bad subordinate
self-care it's more
looking at like what are what are the
assumptions behind this behavior is this
is this true is this something that i
just believe to be true if i have i
proven it i think
where
i see a lot of people going astray when
it comes to things like recovery
and taking breaks is that they do things
that they can justify as taking a break
but really aren't recharging
it's more of a disassociative it's more
of an unplugging a distraction a getting
away
so you know for me i i've i've had the
benefit over the years of finding there
are things that
actually recharge me better than passive
consumption so i try to prioritize
pre-commit create forcing functions
around those things but
i'm only one person it can't say that
the things that are my form of self-care
are everyone's form i said the only way
to to do that is is to try
and again i'm i'm a broken record but
like this stuff is just very simple to
explain but hard to apply
you figure out what works you figure out
how to make this more of a recurring
thing by making it easier to figure out
what gets in the way of the thing that
works how do you make that less likely
to happen so i i think that yeah
self-care
taking breaks
is so so important something that i talk
about often is that your your best ideas
don't come to you at your desk right you
don't just like stare at the text editor
and magic happens a lot of
productive
happenings like ideas
you know generation synthesis happens
you're doing something that's completely
unrelated to the thing you're doing when
you're when you're kicking a ball when
you're taking a walk when you're sitting
in a sauna when you're eating a
delicious bite that maybe you cooked
maybe you're enjoying that
a lot of these other experiences in your
life that are unrelated can't be
decoupled from the thing that you're
trying to do that's why it's like this
thing is productive that this thing is
unproductive i think is a really
unproductive argument all that i can do
is say is like well when things are
seeming to go well these are the other
things that are happening my hypothesis
must be that
these things help me in some way i'm
going to keep doing that or it's like
well i notice that when i skip a workout
or when i watch an entire netflix series
or when i don't go outside or when i
start by checking my email instead of on
my top priority or i don't call my mom
like all these things that the day
doesn't go so well that you know perhaps
doing these things or not doing these
things would be really helpful and
that's why you know you test them and
you find out
one of the things that i loved about
your
stuff on the internet but just before i
started working with you was you have
this performance assessment thing online
which is this like free quiz thing that
i did and i was a bit skeptical i was
like performance assessment well like
what is this it's going to be some like
marketing thing it's going to get me
into a funnel et cetera
and then i did it i was like damn this
is actually good and you've given me
your free book at the end of it like
completely for free and i looked through
and i was like okay i need to pay this
guy to become my coach what is this
performance assessment and how can
people take it thanks yeah the the
challenge that we always have is i only
work with 12 people at a time but i want
to help everyone so this is a tool that
we put a lot of effort into creating the
goal of tell us about what you're doing
in your life and we will tell you here
is the best next action you can take to
improve your performance so having the
benefit of working with over 100 top
performers is start to identify these
recurring elements i usually put these
elements into four main buckets so it's
vision prioritization systems and
presence and so we we drill down say
vision essentially is like what do you
want out of your life are you living a
life of alignment prioritization you
know do you know what's important to you
do those things come first systems are
you making what you want to do easier to
do are you streamlining things creating
processes presence are you doing what's
necessary
typically in terms of habits to show up
as your best self
and we essentially apply a bottleneck
framework to this to thinking about
theory of constraints is like well first
if you don't know what's important to
you well start by figuring out what's
important to you don't worry about all
the other stuff if you're doing the same
thing over and over again and just not
making it easier okay
this thing that you're doing over and
over like how do we create a process
around that how you create something
that improves if you feel like your
energy levels are not high enough to do
what you want to do okay let's start
there you start to drill down into these
four key elements and it reveals here's
the one thing that if you did would have
an immediate impact on your life get
more done
you feel more happy and fulfilled at the
end of the day forget all the other
stuff start there because i think that's
a really big challenge that we have in
the productivity performance space is
that there's just unlimited
opportunities for improvement and vast
majority of them do not move the needle
why because they don't attack the
bottleneck they don't they aren't the
thing that's most holding you back so
that's always the question that i get is
like hey chris you talk about systems
you talk about attention focus energy
time management planning reflection all
these things like oh that's a lot of
things like where do i start
start by taking the performance
assessment and we'll give you that one
thing that you need that will maximally
move you towards your goals and that's
the thing is once you get that up to a
level say okay improve your energy level
all of a sudden everything will become
easier and you can move on to the next
thing so it's like
that's that's the key i find to growth
is figuring out what's that one thing
that if i changed everything becomes
easier so that's why we created it
really yeah we'll put a link to that in
the video description in the show notes
completely free
free ebook like you make enough money
from the other things that you don't
need to charge people ten dollars here
and there for pdfs so
like basically everyone should try this
because because it's actually really
good i'm gonna i'm gonna actually do
this i'm just thinking that like this
would actually make for a really
interesting youtube video i was just
sort of thinking what would the title of
this video be like i don't know 24
questions to level up your life or some
clickbaity title like that yeah it's
it's it's so it's 20 questions and it
gets at all right here the things that
i've seen every peak performer do who's
successful and i take this quiz myself
every quarter to see oh yeah like that
thing works really well maybe i should
start doing that again or maybe i should
do a little bit more of that because i
just like everyone else forget things
that seem to work really well so this is
always a good check in with myself it's
like these are the things that i know
that worked like what are the things
that i should come back to um
these 20 questions leveled up my life
something like that yeah that's a video
so i've got two videos from this number
one how to stop overthinking we're
talking about the idea of plus ev the
idea of thinking in experiments the idea
of status quo bias the idea of fear is a
compass and the consistency thing uh and
then we're doing this other one on 20 20
questions to change your life or
whatever the title of the video is going
to be chris thank you so much this has
been absolutely wonderful where can
people find out more about you absolute
honor ali i have so much fun talking to
you and i really respect how you go
beyond you know productivity tactics and
techniques and thinking about why are we
doing the things that we're doing like
how is what we're doing on a day-to-day
basis getting us to the place we're
doing i really appreciate the work that
you're doing the best place to get a
hold of me is through my company forcing
function
so forcingfunction.com we work with 12
investors and executives at a time we
actually have a very exciting offering
coming up um twice a year we offer
a group coaching program called team
performance training where i walk
through my complete system for peak
performance so here's how to set goals
here's how to create systems here are
the things you need to have to maximize
your time energy attention accelerate
your learning and then we have some
really cool
like you know group coaching exercises
to actually implement these things into
your life instead of just reading about
them so if you're interested in that go
to teamperformancetraining.com another
great place to start as ali said is our
performance assessment you can find that
at
forcingfunction.com
assessment probably the best place to
find me on social media would be twitter
my handle on all the networks is at
sparks remarks and if you want to email
me directly my email is chris at my
website chris thank you so much it's
been wonderful have a great day and
we'll see you next time all right so
that's it for this week's episode of
deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye